Hey.
And we are. Yes. Nice.
>> We are live.
>> Yes. Let's go.
>> Let's go.
>> Uh tech. I'm just going to retreat that.
Boom. Let's go. Let's go. Let's [__]
go. Nice. Welcome. Welcome to any in the
chat. I don't know if maybe T will join.
We don't know.
>> We will see.
>> Stay with you if you if you watch. Love
you. Love you, bro. [laughter]
And otherwise, please scroll back to the
beginning.
>> Yeah, exactly. [laughter]
>> Uh, okay. So, what you thinking, man?
>> Was live. Yeah, we had a big issue
tonight.
>> Was offline. [laughter]
>> I hate that like API blah blah blah. And
then can't do can't do anything. I need
to create content. No,
>> I actually I had to Google the status
page. [laughter]
>> Yeah. The status bar was Yeah.
>> No, exactly. Yeah. I went to the
entropic status page. It was all around.
Yeah. We investigate the issue and
investigate faster, bro, because I don't
know my code base anymore.
>> How hard can be. You have AI. Press fix
it.
>> Yeah. Exactly. That's true.
>> Yeah.
>> They built everything themselves with
their own AI, right?
>> Oh, yeah. like a cloud code is writing
by itself like Yeah.
>> So if it goes offline, it's on AWS
>> could be. Oh yeah. Um
uh
did they ever mention an AI inside the
data center?
>> No, but I know I think there are AWS,
right? Because AWS is one of the big
investors.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. the
architecture like all of the server it's
all about. Yeah, because when they got
like bomb in Dubai they had an issue
with theation too. Yeah, true.
>> Or was it the Microsoft data center? I
don't know.
>> Maybe they use all of them.
>> Well, at least we will get back to you.
But
>> yeah,
>> they had an outage so that was not good.
>> Oh, Amazon again.
>> No, no, no. Cloud.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. But yeah, not Amazon,
right?
>> I was just checking. It's It's running.
It's up and up again. So
>> that's good.
>> Oh, nice. Okay. So, let's let's do the
stream then we can come back go back to
prompting and viing software
engineering.
>> Let's start with the introduction first.
>> True, true, true, true, true. So, I will
try to make it. Do you still don't want
to do it?
>> I don't have the introduction here.
>> Oh, it's
>> you gave it to me, but
>> I have it, but uh yeah, I will have to
like, you know, uh make it more natural.
It's about te right all right.
>> Yeah, but I don't want to talk about him
in this [laughter]
>> Well, do your thing.
>> Cool.
>> Um, yes. [clears throat]
[laughter]
Have you ever opened a pull request in a
massive open source project? Because
cloud code did it too and maybe it and
it's like more than 40% of all of
submission on GitHub now. Uh so it's uh
and it's creating way more uh a lot of
issues. Yeah, I I will edit that but
that would be good.
Um
yeah. Uh oh yeah and Theo drop a video
about open source is dying. Yeah mention
it. Whatever.
And Theo drop a video about saying the
open source is dying. Is it true? Is it
all AI slope? That's what we're going to
talk about in this uh video today.
>> Let's go.
>> The magic of editing will do the rest.
[laughter]
>> But you said cloud is creating pull
requests and creating more issues.
>> Yeah. Yes. [clears throat]
Is that confusing?
>> Yeah, that's no good. AI is is supposed
to work, [laughter]
>> bro. Like uh I I asked [__] to onto
codeex and code and my code is still
buggy. So, and I need to do the QA. So,
yeah.
>> Yeah. Did you use uh any pull request
that that cloud did? Let me rephrase.
That was a that was a way way worse
question. [laughter]
Have you ever done any pull request to
support on open source? Oh, um not I
don't think so. No, not that remember.
So, I I guess I would remember. Uh so I
have zero experience of open source
basically because I I had other stuff to
do. I had I wanted to be like I was
always the main developer for startups
and I would rather like work on a
startup project that going to pay me
after than contributing to open source.
But I watched a video from Theo again
about open source and stuff and he spend
a lot of time in there. and the best
developer in the Silicon Valley, they
have their Google, Amazon jobs and then
in the weekend they work on open source
projects.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And I mean contributing to a
project with like thousand of other
developers that trying to uh correct
your own pull request. Uh that's as
you have to [snorts] be good.
>> Yeah. I only did it on smaller projects
and I think the only thing I did was
Dutch adding Dutch translations.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. When the AI could not do
it for you, right?
>> Yeah. So, I added them and I used the
plugin and that's it.
>> Yeah. Like could you imagine like being
Peter from like open CL repository when
you have like all of the AI stuff
opening pull request and stuff?
>> No, I I wouldn't even know how to manage
it. I bro I don't think they manage it.
>> They just let it rip.
>> I mean okay let me open
>> you have so many but not just the pull
requests all the people writing all the
post and complaining and writing issues
and you have to reply all we already
took care of this one know it's related
to this one. Yeah.
>> How do you do it?
>> Yeah I guess you need to know the code
really well [laughter]
>> and be online 247. Yeah, bro. Like look
5,000 5,000 issues.
>> Yeah. And 5,000 P request.
Try merging those.
>> Yeah.
And even the compute required to check
all of that stuff
like good luck. And okay, so for
example, this one fix mode for operator
to CLI. Describe the problem and fix it
in two five bullet point doc doesn't
align with source code. Oh, that's
annoying. Uh, no operator defined. Fair
enough. Okay. Grab that. Yeah. And also
there is more and more like AI tools to
like review all of the P request. So I I
would I would merge this one. Please
Peter match this one.
>> Yes. Thank you.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
But normally you would have like two or
three people who are doing this for free
and just for fun writing down uh
replying to everybody giving comments
>> and those are reply replaced by AI. I
think
>> it has to be like okay fix rest
condition between prompt and herbit.
Okay prompt fixes this issues blah blah
blah grab tile review. Yeah see there is
not even
>> a human reviewer at all.
So that that's B. Okay. Open CL
repository is the future of open source
basically.
>> Yeah. AI fixing AI.
>> Yeah. I mean like if you have the test
and if you have all of the uh
fundamentals to run all of those proto
Yeah. The problem is like you're gonna
you're going to pay a lot in compute.
>> Yeah. But I don't think that's the
issue.
>> They are part of OpenAI right now.
>> No. Yes. But like uh in one of the
interview like Peter made it was like
the cost of like running open claw by
himself was like 15 grand a month.
>> It was manageable cost.
>> Um
I'm wondering how much is it like toh
just run GitHub actions to check the
pull request on GitHub.
>> Yeah, I never tried so I don't know but
it's massive. Okay. So, uh we wanted to
talk about that because like I mentioned
in my fabulous introduction, I really
need to work the introduction for the
videos because uh
>> it's the hook. Oh,
>> it's getting viewers.
>> Yes,
>> we we had some viewers.
>> the channel is going up. We even got
some some replies from people. So,
that's perfect.
>> And that's why your sound is way better
this week.
>> Yeah. If somebody tells me I need to buy
a new mic, I will buy one. Yeah. So, in
the comments, please tell Mitchell to
give me some money. Oh, okay. No, you
[laughter]
>> I won't do everything that people write
down,
>> but Okay. So, Theo uh one I think like
one of the most preminent uh dev uh and
software engineer
um on YouTube. Like I I know I watch him
and like the primogen now and like
couple of other guys uh because of AI.
Honestly, before AI, I didn't even watch
any software engineer content on
YouTube.
>> No, it was boring and you had to just
test so much yourself to even understand
what they were doing.
>> Yeah, that's interesting. No, you're
right. Because now that AI makes like
software engineering easier, then you
can spend more time with like feedbacks
from other developers and trying more
tools because everything is easier.
>> Yeah. But the cool thing is you can even
even take the video, put it in an open
claw, say watch this and use it to
improve yourself and it does it.
>> Yeah. I do that all the time. Like for
example, okay, so for this uh notion
talking point
>> Mhm. for this live stream I dropped the
the video and asked to summarize it even
if I watched it and then we have like
talking content segment from [snorts]
that video like yeah it's crazy I love
it
>> yeah the only thing that people were uh
on X posting about is that you have to
make sure that the video does not have
some secret messages in it so it doesn't
keep repeating weird stuff that open
will read and do and then
>> you have an issue
>> prompt injections
>> yeah
H
they had an example of a video that can
do that.
>> No, I couldn't find it, but they were
talking about it that it might be
tricky.
>> You can even do that in an image.
>> Yeah. Well, maybe we will have we we can
try it. We can put some in our videos
and see what it does. Like like a video
on YouTube. See this URL?
>> Oh, that would be sick. I I don't know
if it works, but
>> like like a QR code, but inside Oh, like
>> like a secret message for Open Claw for
an AI agent that you don't see.
>> Oh, that would be sick. That's a good
>> That will be cool to test.
>> Yes, that's pretty cool.
[snorts] Uh but okay, so yeah, Theo open
source is dying and will AI will kill
OSS. So everyone, okay, I'm going to go
drop the video in the chat because uh
yeah, everyone needs to watch that.
Poof. Okay, cool. Uh will AI kill open
source? Uh the problem will be like uh P
spam and slop which is like yeah I'm
going to uh put my code against one repo
saying analyzed it and open a pull
request so I can increase my GitHub
stars and contribution and stuff and
start and capis. So, I'm a good
developer. Uh, dumber and angry user aka
like um
someone who never did any um
uh development before prior to AI. It's
just like a femod now because they
unlocked everything and now they getting
like entitled to u uh merge whatever the
[__] they they have created to a repo.
Uh install versus prompt. Yeah.
He was even talking about uh maybe not
this point. Okay, I don't know exactly
the install versus promp, but it was
even saying um on Reddit someone posted
that why um where is the install button?
I don't want the source code. I want I
just want uh you to give me theexit and
that's it.
>> Yeah.
>> So that those kind of people are going
on GitHub now.
>> Yeah. and they only know how to download
a Windows program and doubleclick it.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Well, we had the other one who said, "I
built this amazing website. I prompted
it. Everything works and the URL is
local host."
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Yeah. There's a lot of meme on Twitter.
Yeah. I know nothing about code, but
what I've done is beautiful. Check it
out. It's local. [clears throat]
Um so yeah like so yeah and AI will kill
OSS and some funding problems but yeah
it's free like it's open you open source
the code the the code so nobody will pay
for it you ask for uh tips tips and
stuff but uh yeah you can have 50 50k
thousand stars on GitHub and get 50
bucks at the end of the month so
>> yeah no use
>> a problem um and then talking about uh
Uh
should we watch it? We watch some.
>> Yeah, we can watch some. We have time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh tag. Okay. So Oh,
whoopsie.
Uh yes. Or whatever. Whatever. Like the
moment. So PR spam fooding repo. Sorry s
in tech
stuff. Oh yeah. And blacksmith is is
showing up blacksmith because of like
the GitHub contribution and I'm using
it. uh thanks to him and it's it's like
a a better GitHub action than GitHub
action because they are caching the
they are caching like the images they
are basically doing a better job than
GitHub on their own layer and it's going
it's going faster so you save some
compute usage so you can deploy more and
you can have more AI reviewing your code
because you deploy more so you test more
etc etc
Uh yes. So
>> uh do that. Check check it blackmith.
Sorry that your links use it.
>> We have no sound.
>> What?
>> Ah uh we don't hear it.
>> Oh,
wait. I'm going to check YouTube. Maybe
you are the only one not hearing it.
>> Yeah. So, if you can hear it in the
chat, please reply.
>> Yeah. Let me check replay.
Oh, no. Nobody. Oh,
okay.
Why?
Uh,
okay. Maybe this one. Can you still hear
me?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I can.
>> Nope, not me. I can't hear you. Okay, so
multitrack and Oh, wait, wait, wait. I
know. Uh, is it muted?
Uh,
>> didn't hear it, right?
>> Yeah. Try it one more time.
No.
M.
What the heck?
Oh, wait.
Just a question. Did you stay up just
for the special for the show? [laughter]
>> Answer it. Oh. Oh. Uh, thanks. Is that
is that your dad?
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter]
>> Okay. Let me
>> find of the first day. Perfect.
>> What about that?
[clears throat]
God damn. Oh, [__] it up.
I can hear you. Damn. Okay. I don't know
why.
Okay. So, I think I will fix it for next
time because I will have to move it
anyway, but I'm gonna just like stop it
on the videos. Um,
yeah. Okay, cool. Uh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, so yeah, technical difficulties.
Why is that not coming up?
That's weird.
Input chat.
Hm.
No, it should. Ah, okay. Oh, I think I
know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I
know. It's because
>> on zero.
>> No, no, no, no. I don't have the It was
not in the same windows. That's why. Uh,
okay. So, if I do that, oh, point. We
don't want that. No performance warning.
Not that. Sorry. Back up. Share screen.
Uh,
drive tab. Live back.
Boom.
Okay. No,
not me. I I will I will I will get it. I
will get it. this one. Share this one.
Okay. And now if I do that, if I do
that, a
>> lot of sympathy for people draw that.
>> Perfect.
>> I'm a software engineer. [laughter]
>> Did you ask AI how to do it?
>> Uh I I remember that stream is kind of
garbage with like the multitab because I
I was sharing another window where I
have my [__] point blah blah and uh
was not the correct focus. Uh Dad, can
you please uh um uh tell us if you can
hear the video, but should be fine.
>> Put out this change where they're just
going to start closing any external
contributions because they're just
>> Please confirm, but should we should be
good. Uh and thanks for the engagement.
Okay, so I'm going to keep that here.
Reorganizing
puff buff.
Okay.
So, back to that.
But Michelle, you can hear it, right?
So,
>> yeah, it works.
>> Yeah. Okay. Nice.
So, three
back. Then there's the dumber, angrier
users problem. Install versus prompt.
And biggest probably is the funding
problems. First, we're going to start
with the PR spam problem. I've been
pretty aware of this for a while and I
have a lot of sympathy for people like
TL Draw that put out this change where
they're just going to start clo
>> so they are just closing every external
contribution because it's getting out of
hand to uh basically manage all of the
issues like we can notice it on open but
then that like from perspective that's
basically killing open source because
then you don't have contributors at all
so what's the what's the point of open
source
closing any external contributions
because they're just getting flooded
with them. And I knew how bad this was
and it helped other maintainers dealing
with it in the past. But this problem is
much closer to my heart now because
we're going through it ourselves. The T3
Code codebase, which has been public for
about 5 days now, has 150 open PRs. Mind
you, we specified that we're not
accepting contributions and we still got
100 PRs a day for the first two days. It
remind me crypto project.
>> Yeah. Yeah. People don't read, people
do.
>> Yeah. Like people don't give a [__] and
they will do it because it will benefit
from them and that's it. Like it's
>> And then comes the question
>> they will do it.
>> When when when
>> exactly like it's open open source is a
crypto project.
And that's a clip. We have a clip.
>> Yeah.
I eventually added this because I was
tired of saying the same things over and
over again in all of the PRs. We're not
actively accepting PRs. You can still
open issue your PR, but please do so
knowing there's a high chance we close
it, defer it forever, and never look at
it. Exponentially worse. And literally
all of my Sunday just sitting going
through PRs, testing things, shipping
new releases, just dealing with that.
And
why?
He just said he wasn't going to do it
and now he still does it. So people are
now even going to put more PRs in.
>> Yes. Yes. Yeah. Exactly. But like No,
but what I'm saying is like why is he
doing it manually?
>> I don't know.
>> Don't don't
>> maybe we should shoot should in a PR
telling him hey autoate it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean [laughter]
why because also like um I know he he
explained that for a couple of side
projects he didn't review like he didn't
code anything like for this side project
it same thing like like me for gen right
like the genre I like I review a lot and
I try and do QA and all of the side
project I don't I don't I don't care if
they exist or not for now it's not the
focus then I just I just let the AI um
building it the way it wants and then we
move forward from there and then I will
QA when I will have five minutes to QA.
Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But that's the solution,
right? You said I don't care of it. If
he is really proud on the project and he
wants to make sure that everything is
correct,
>> then does he trust an AI to do the
reviewing of the PRs?
>> But then like the we need to let go.
>> Oh yeah. We need to let as like a AI
architect, we need to let go like the
and trust trust AI even like like bro I
spend like before this show I spent like
an hour just like looping between
bugs and like yeah it's like fix
something reopen something and then for
whatever reason I have two agents in
parallel and then the agent is saying
the drift from the the first one and
then it corrected put it back the the
like I was working on the sidebar and I
wanted one item done and it's like, "Oh,
this item was like deleted by a lint or
something. I should put it back." And
then [__] put it back off.
>> If you did it manually, how much work
was it?
>> Oh, uh, [laughter]
>> one second.
>> Yeah, but for him for the pull request,
he was doing them all manually. I think
even if he just had an AI to take out
all the double ones, all the ones who
were obviously wrong,
>> that [clears throat] would have saved
him a lot of time. Yeah, but Evan I
think he's still doing it anyway. Like
he still have like C rabbit or even like
the grapple. He using all of that
because because he's promoting them at
the beginning of his videos like all of
that of the tools he used. He's using as
um as a he put them as a as an ad or he
get like sponsorship for his channel
>> and so I know he use all of that and I
know he covers all of those processes
with AI tooling already, right? and he
has a team.
>> So he has also like two three dev I
think um to work on those project too.
So but could be the scale like I don't
know the scale issue.
>> Yeah, it probably is because otherwise
it doesn't make sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm somebody who likes doing
those types of things and it was still
draining for me. I basically couldn't do
anything Monday because I was so tired
from the whole weekend of triaging,
managing PRs, going through issues. I
had to bring two people on just to help
keep track of the PRs and issues. And
there's only 150 PR
>> like that's taking three people.
>> Mad. It's mad.
>> How many did Open Claw have? 5K.
>> Yeah. 5K. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. But the guy got paid like 1
billion, so shut the [__] up.
>> He doesn't care. He he even pays a bill
for the AI.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like makes sense.
>> It's bigger problem and it kind of
touches on this classic post on Reddit.
>> That that was the the Reddit like
because I watched this video before it
like before this week. I don't I don't
give a [__] about the [__] code. I
just want to download this stupid
[__] application and use it. Uh
GitHub link. Why is Why is there Why is
there code? Make a [__] X file and
give me it to me. Give it to me.
GitHub is a tool for developers. If
you're not a developer, then GitHub is
the wrong place for you to looking for
software. [laughter]
>> And then the worst thing is there are
always people replying.
>> Yeah, I mean they are probably both su
but like and 100% like there is a high
chance that was a suggestion from uh
Chad GPT who cl
oh you should check this uh application
and then it redirects. Yeah,
>> like it's probably a Rico. Um, okay. So,
>> we're kind of [__] nerds and that's
awesome. I love that about us. I love
the fact that we have this crew of
>> talking about this community here.
Whatever. Whatever. Chat, chat, chat.
Cool. Um,
>> and someone filed a nonsense PR that
tried to fix all of those things and
ended up just breaking other things.
like here he's explaining like a big PR
is hard to it's basically garbage and it
doesn't follow the like the proper
etiquette of open source and even like
software engineering per se like uh on
my local host I will edit 10,00 file
don't do it on a open source project
[laughter]
and explain that and yeah after he's
talking about like yeah minimum um uh
the size of the yeah like compare it to
Another uh small uh pull request.
Uh blah blah blah. Yeah. Uh okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
>> We are stuck as a
>> hyped with what Mitchell is creating. If
you're not familiar with him, he's
not
>> the guy who made Ghosty as well as
Terraform. Mitchell knows his [__] He
built Vouch because he was tired of the
nonsense PRs he was getting in things
like Ghosty. Funny enough, Vouch has two
PRs open and eight issues, which is
insane, especially considering how
useful and used this project is. So,
what is Vouch? Community trust
management system. People must be vouch
for before interacting with certain
parts of a project. People can
explicitly be denounced to block them
from interacting with the project going
forward. You said,
>> which crazy is that [__] is not a
[__] GitHub feature.
Yeah, you just allow some people and not
the whole world to just create pull
requests.
>> Exactly. But like still people can fork
it and like star it and do whatever the
[__] they want after that. But yeah, why
do you do I have to accept 5,000 pull
request from a guy who created an
account yesterday?
>> Yeah. [laughter]
[snorts] even like okay so in the video
he explained that uh he he banned some
contributors because they were useless
and those banned contributors are
creating an account to comment below the
issue saying Theo is a dumbass and they
should merge the PR and it's the same
guy.
>> Yeah. So they have no life at all.
>> No internet bro like they got time on
internet. They got time.
Uh okay and so for the other point
um
yeah so yeah Dra G will not ser
I don't remember the point of install
for these open source maintainers the
likelihood somebody even engages enough
to care about the maintainer has gone
down and if they even do get that far
the likelihood they spend money has also
gone down. So the upsides of open source
which are the proliferation of your
software, the proliferation of your
ideas and the potential to get funded
for those things that has gone down a
ton. But the burden
>> except if you build open.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, you always have the unicorns.
>> Yeah, true.
>> Of open source maintenance has gone up a
ton. And that ratio shift terrifies me.
And this is where we need to do
something. The open source pledge is a
great start but it is just the start.
The open source pledge is can do other
than opening PRs and I really want you
to try and embody the problem before you
do anything in a repo like this. The
biggest problem
>> so no it's like some education about
yeah consuming open source
>> but still most people don't care they
just create a PR and they put in code
that they think is good.
Yeah, because again like uh if you're
looking for a job, if you can say that
you are contributed to open CL
repository and you have like 15
contribution merge, then it's good for
you.
>> Even if you have the green blocks for
over a full year,
>> people like to see it and that only
works on public uh repositories.
>> I know exactly. And plus, okay, so he
also had another uh because that's not
the only problem for open source. He had
another video
tag where uh Okay. So, in uh open source
uh don't contri. Yes.
How do I contribute? No, that's not this
one.
Uh
oh. Maybe it changed the
Oh, that's us. Let's go.
Uh, oops. Or I pass billion of fro
whatever whatever open source.
Uh, how do I contribute
contri maybe I will not find it. Contri
but um like you have people opening
update of MD files just to have some
contribution.
>> Yeah. and they just update the date or
whatever just to show that they can do
something.
>> Yes.
So yeah and again like just to build up
your resume and saying yeah yeah I have
like 200 contribution
you you see the same thing on on
WordPress you can just have cloud app uh
managing your browser putting in all the
translations pushing it and you you were
the one adding something to that project
>> and then you can show your customers hey
I've been working on so many projects
and my name is here and
>> people who don't get it they just think
that you're doing a lot of good things
for WordPress and they give you a new
project.
>> Yeah, it's like how do you get like a
five star on uh not UD me but uh ah the
stuff for contractors.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh what's the name of it?
>> The um [clears throat]
where all where all the the people are
putting the work.
>> No,
>> Fiverr. Yes. Or Fiverr. Yeah. How to get
five star. So, but you can buy it
[laughter]
>> and you can also like uh create multiple
accounts, I guess, and they'll give you
more even more stars and stuff, but uh
or you can just Yeah. having your
friends opening like more fake project
and then give you five star and say,
"Oh, yeah, it's good."
>> Yeah. And you take a job like coding to
lines for $10 and you buy a fivestar
review.
>> It's nice. So, yeah, like people will
game the game, right? Um but again like
even if it's not
with the model of like today's model
like um
>> 4 4.5 and uh
4 4 no 5.4 and 4.6 six for cloud um opus
um
why AI is not writing all of the
opensource
code in the universe
>> I think eventually it will it will just
take a few more updates
>> and all the problems that he's
discussing right now in his videos they
will be gone
>> yeah exactly it's like you know like um
u Samman was uh replying to the question
Okay. Uh when everyone will get fired
for the job because they will be like
redundant and useless. What will uh uh
what are we going to do as a human?
We're going to ask AI what else we can
what we can do. Right.
>> Do you have any ideas for my Sunday?
>> Yeah.
>> So yeah. And do you think like there is
still a future even like for closed
source anyway?
>> Yeah, I think there will be. But if you
have a job where your um employer is
asking you to write down everything you
do and to document everything, then
you're going to be jobless.
>> And yeah, we saw that on Twitter too,
right? Like a lot of developers are
documenting their replacement by or
becoming like data training for their
own job.
>> Yeah, by being a good employee.
I mean, you need you need to document
everything because then you also like
create a process for the rest of the
team to like work like you, right? But
now the rest of the team is like five
agents.
>> Yes. [laughter]
[snorts]
>> But again, if anyone is building their
own carrier and like their own solo fund
or company, then it's whatever. Well, we
have been doing it and it's going crazy.
>> Yeah, it's not. Uh, did you increase
like your revenue since AI?
>> Uh, yeah, for sure.
>> Yeah, me too. Yeah. [laughter]
>> No, no, no. I actually did. So,
>> and still it's only one just me doing
all the work.
>> No, no, that's nuts. That that's that's
nuts. And like do you walk more?
Uh yes, but I think that's a that's a
problem with
different things.
>> First of all, I like it. So when I start
a project,
>> Exactly.
>> I just keep on going because it goes so
fast and you can just do one more thing.
>> Just asking one more thing and before
you know, you're 30 minutes further and
>> you have built like three features and
you need to debug everything and deploy
it and yeah, then then it's another day
further. That's my life for the last 12
months, bro. [laughter]
>> Just one more prompt. Just one more
prompt.
>> But yeah. Um Yeah. But even like
because it's it's everyone can do it
like not everyone can do it well first
>> and also uh then not everyone will love
it anyway. And because there is more and
more people doing it then there is even
more needs and more problem to come up
with the mass of people creating new uh
yeah companies and project and stuff. So
yeah but it is also with your customers.
Before I was the one doing the research
sending them stuff they would read it
and give it back to me.
>> Now they have AI and needs to research
for their own website and give me a full
list. Hey can can you do this? Yeah,
>> because they know how to research it.
They know how to find what to improve,
but they don't have the knowhow on how
to actually do it.
>> Yeah.
>> But and even I am fast enough with AI
and they know it. But still you you
still have enough work. But the speed in
what they give you improvements to do.
Yeah. Compared to a year ago, it's
insane.
>> Yeah. And even like it improved the
communication between like uh your
client and yourself like you you can say
something technical and if they don't
understand it they drop it in GPT and
okay you get a technical answer back.
[laughter]
>> Oh yeah trust him. Pay him though.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the only thing they don't
want you to do is to call them and
[laughter] and start talking. Please put
it on the email.
>> That's true. Uh yeah but okay. So for
open source like is there a world where
even like closed source or SAS project
should incorporate some opensource
vertical for distribution GTM or like
aspect of it.
>> Yeah. But don't you think that
eventually people will start it because
they have an idea they put it online and
then AI will take over. It will just
keep on improving.
>> Yeah.
Uh okay.
I mean, yeah. So, [snorts] improving
what? Like your open source code?
>> Yeah. Because eventually, why would an
AI create open source? Because it can
build everything at once. So, usually
open source comes from people having
issues trying to find a good solution,
publishing it online, other people have
the same issue, and everybody starts
building together and then you get a
bigger and bigger project and eventually
a a big open source project. But I think
as soon as you start pushing it online
and like a few people start using it
then the AIs come in because they put
the AI on it to improve it. Yeah. And
then it it can go exponentially.
>> Yeah. Okay. So what could be the purpose
of open source in five years
in six months? Um
>> it will be the replacement of the SAS.
>> Yeah. because it's so big, so complex,
and you can just import it and your AI
will work with it
>> and you don't have to pay for SAS
anymore. [snorts]
I I Okay.
For for a SAS that will serve dev
maybe.
>> Mhm. But for PE like uh a B2B SAS or
like outside I don't know like outside
of like technical roles people still
like I like they don't understand AI
they don't understand technology and it
will go way slower than expected so
we're going to change the UI of the SAS
>> but I don't think we like we will just
shut down everything and everything will
be like a chat GPT conversation, you
know, because again like like my like
point of view, what I want to say is
like
if I go on a chat GPT interface, I I
need to know what I'm going to looking
for to ask for it.
>> Mhm. But if I have an interface and I
can just go it for five second then
instead of typing or like talking to the
AI and it will like take me like 10
seconds to type or like say it and then
get the answer
compared to a dashboard going to the
dashboard and click on one button to
export it in my Excel spreadsheet
because Excel spreadsheet are not going
anywhere.
>> No, no, no. It will just be a dashboard
that is created for you in the chat.
>> Yeah, exactly. But like the dashboard
will always be the same. And also like
what's is there any like that amount of
friction to have a dynamic dashboard
for having a SAS d a s a sass dashboard
that have been defied by a guy in uh at
3:00 a.m. in the morning like you know I
mean
>> yeah I don't see them using anymore
because what I think is if you have a
web shop and you are integrating Google
ads Facebook ads and everything into
your chat GPT and you read all the data
in
>> and you have chat GPT integrated into
your project and you are discussing your
goals and your marketing with CHGPT it
knows everything that you want to
>> so before you even start up CHP knows
what do I need to give him today. How
far are we on the goals? What are
additional benefits that we can do for
him to even get more revenue and more
sales? So,
dashboards, I don't think you will need
them anymore. It will just know what to
send you. And even if you say, "Hey, I
want to do something different today. I
want to do this." It will regenerate the
entire dashboard for you.
>> Yeah.
>> Or the report.
>> But that's still a UI.
>> Yeah. But not a not a standard dashboard
SAS. Yeah. I mean, yeah. And yeah, like
the like the AI the UI is still
generated by an AI uh in the back end,
but then at the end of the day, you
still need a SAS to have that display
for even if your SAS is just a [__]
web page that is completely fully
autonomous
morphism design stuff that just going to
pop up the the block in your face.
>> Yeah. But open can do it as well.
>> True. Yeah. in a in a Telegram chat like
this, WhatsApp or whatever, right?
>> Yeah. But also just a dashboard locally
on your Mac, so you don't need need
>> Yeah. You don't need to go to the big
ones anymore.
>> Yeah. But I don't believe that. I I
don't believe like I don't know.
>> Yeah. Then you still need someone to set
it up for you.
>> Exactly. Like uh Yeah. Or we need to
reach productization productization of
AI like level 100.
>> Yeah.
And I I still see that people don't like
that they don't know what it will cost
>> because eventually the AI is going to
run and it will cost you API calls.
>> Yeah. But then the API calls will be
0.001.
>> Yeah. But it's so hard to say what the
cost will be and eventually they will
just keep on going
>> and they get the bill at the end of the
month.
>> Yes. Yeah. That's why yeah you want to
build to yeah like us usage based uh
billing will be a big shift for big
corporate because it's not something you
can count every month.
>> No.
>> But then the the the seat model doesn't
make sense anyway because you you don't
need 50 like 10,000 seat on your
software anymore. You just need one that
will because it's one agent.
>> Yeah. And if you have a big input, you
have a big output and a big bill. And
during the summer holidays,
>> yeah,
>> you're not paying that much. So that
makes sense.
>> Yeah. But you don't have a provisional
like you don't you you can't like
estimate, okay, like my software expense
is like 10% of my business. If you have
a a usage output then um
uh yeah a billing based on the output
and the usage
>> then uh yeah it will be like one in
January because everyone's still
sleeping in Christmas naps but it during
summer yeah it will be like 200 so you
and you don't want that because you
don't know
>> yeah eventually you will after a few
months you can do an average
>> yeah
So that I think that's consultant
consultancy by us right we know
eventually after helping so many
customers smart averages
but yeah like yeah service did you see
like the form
seoa sea report like the services is a
new s
>> nope didn't see it
>> you are going to show it
>> yes sir
Yeah. Uh services is the new us.
Uh nice nice. Not interested.
Yes.
So good with memory. Nice.
So it's completely out of the scope of
open source.
>> Yeah. But hopefully we have a good video
and we just need to do the but yeah
whatever. Uh okay so services is the new
software. So SEOA one one of the biggest
investors in the Silicon Valley
ecosystem. Um the next one trillion
company will be a software company
masquerading as a services firm. Genfe
it's called genfit.
>> We already have it. Every founder
building an AI tool is asking the same
question. What happened when the next
version of code makes my product a
feature? They are right to worry. If you
sell the tool, you are race against the
model. But if you sell the work, aka the
output,
>> every improvement in the model and makes
your service faster, cheaper, harder to
compete with. And company might spend
10k a year for QuickBooks and 100K on an
accountant to close the books, which is
like Yeah. nuts.
Change the law.
>> Yeah. And probably if you put their work
in AI right now, it will give back like
so many mistakes and possible
improvements.
>> Yeah. Oops. 1%. Yeah. It's not like it's
just just pay Quickbook 50K.
[laughter]
>> Uh yeah, the next generary company will
just close the books. Yeah, exactly. Uh
intelligence versus judgment. Writing
coin is mostly intelligence. Knowing
what to build next is judgment. Bro,
it's so hard. And it's way harder. It's
way harder. like always one prompt away
of like the next epic.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh translating the spec into cut testing
debugging the rules are complex but they
are rules judgment is different. It
require exper experience and test
instinct build on years of practice. Uh
if you are a young developer you're so
[__]
>> Yeah. If you still have one year in
school to go [laughter]
>> just just drop out now.
>> Yeah.
uh deciding which feature to build next,
whether to take a technical depth, where
when to ship before it's ready. Let's
go.
>> Yeah, we used to do that when we didn't
have AI, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Ship it, build it, and then fix every
bug as soon as possible.
>> Yeah. On production with customers.
Let's go.
>> Yeah.
>> My QA services, man.
>> Updating the database and data in live
version.
>> Yeah. Because why not? Dry mode. What is
dry mode?
>> Who uses that? [laughter]
>> A year ago, most cursor user treated AI
as autocomplete. Today, more tasks are
started by agent by humans aka chron
jobs.
>> Yes.
>> Crunch jobs and workbooks.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Software engineering account for over
half of the tools blah blah blah. Okay.
Software engineering got there first.
It's coming to every single profession.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Oh yeah. In which
domain are agent deployed software
engineering 50%.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh copilot and autopilot. I I don't
think we are autopilot just yet. Like
it's it's just like yeah AI is like a
big guy sitting close to me but uh still
double checking everything kind of
uh okay the the higher the inance ratio
in any field the sooner autopilot will
win.
>> Mhm. [clears throat] The higher the
intelligence ratio in any field that's
okay convergence today's judgment will
becomes to more intelligence as AI
system accumulate appropriated data
about what good judgments look like in
that domain the frontier will shift
co-pilots and autopilot will converge uh
the autopilot playbook outsourcing okay
for every dollar I spent on software six
are spent on services
>> so you know where to go next
>> yeah I It makes sense. And YC had also
like the AI agency stuff, right? Again,
you fully automated like the process
with AI and you sell the output and
that's a banger like maybe you're right
like maybe the SAS will not you will you
will sell seed because it's whatever you
will sell the output and it will be used
by you. You are building your own tools
to sell the output for your customers.
>> Yeah. And I still think if a customer is
happy paying 50k a year for the
software, for the SAS because he makes
so much profit,
>> Yeah.
>> he will just keep paying 50K if it works
100% of the time until the market is
fully educated.
>> Yeah.
Because then like Okay. So then it's
like offer demand, right? Like okay,
your customer is paying 50K because he
has customers are going to pay 30. But
when those customer who pay s will go to
the fully AI automated uh film that's
going to charge them 50 bucks
uh then uh then then
>> yeah yeah yeah but still there is so
much more to do so you it
>> it can't drop in price but not so hard
and
>> yeah and and it it's going to take like
30 years because
>> yeah because all of us we are the IT
guys we see the changes every day and we
think it's going to be tomorrow that
we're out of a job. But
>> yeah, but it's good for us, right?
Because we have this sentiment of
urgency and uh then we act fast and then
we are ready. But uh we are ready for
the next 10.
>> Yeah, just wait for three years when the
impact comes to the to the second amount
of people and we are just walking
around. Oh yeah, that happened three
years ago.
>> Oh, I had my open close setup. What what
are you doing? [laughter]
>> Are you you still using cursor? You're
so 2025.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh [snorts]
opportunity maps floating every services
vertical and intelligence to judgment
copilot management consulting 300
billion. What the [__]
Uh geographic UXUI 30 billion. Executive
search 20B here and comes 20B. Autopilot
territory insurance
just die.
IT managed services 100 billion payroll
50 claims whatever whatever watch
judgment insults recruitment 200 what
the like other
>> you stepped out of recruitment right
[laughter]
>> why
sold the sold the company made the money
by
>> yeah I really think if you do it right
now and just do it as a side project
totally built by AI don't look at it.
Have AI do everything.
>> Yeah.
>> With the knowledge that you already have
and maybe the the the people that you
know
>> that can scale hard as well.
>> Yeah. But who are you going to recruit
if everyone is losing their job?
>> There will always be opportunities.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh, for sure. like everyone
will will want like even a company that
grow anywhere thanks to uh thanks to AI
they will hire AI architect for whatever
the job is anyway so
>> and if you just hire one AI architect
>> exactly
>> that's a big guy so you earn a lot
>> yeah like the guy is getting paid like
half a million you take
>> you take a percentage
>> yeah true for just like having an open
close email sent let's go
>> and promise beer on Friday night.
[laughter]
>> Uh, next wave supply chain procurement.
Yeah.
Evan like all of like plotting is Yeah.
Okay. Um,
if that's true like the market will get
even bigger in those all of those
categories.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So they talk about that
recruitment
I think the largest service market on
the list. Jesus
uh the top of hiring finale screening
matching outreach is pure intelligence
but closing a candidate and assessing
culture fit is judgment built on years
on pattern recognition. The autopilot
wedge exist in high volume low judant
roles where matching is standardized.
Juice box merco jack and are emerging
leader building across the spectrum.
Okay. Yeah. Marco Marco like had crazy
revenue uh growth like insane.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. There will always need people
whatever. I guess even if we don't want
to I guess other people want to work.
>> It will still be needed.
>> Yeah. And yeah, if you build one, reach
out. Okay. I'm I'm gonna email Jillian.
>> Send them the email.
>> Yeah. Marketing, right? And ads. Ads.
Ads. uh add there. They didn't mention
ad
>> I don't think so. I didn't see it but
>> uh management graphic. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. It's not really ads but uh
>> but online ads are done by Google and
Facebook so you can't compete.
>> Oh like the Yeah. Okay.
>> They will they will automate it for you.
Oh. Oh. You think you think you will
drop like the the ad that what you want
to sell to Google and they will generate
10 best ads on the platform?
>> Yeah,
>> I think they will because eventually for
them they will lose a lot of income
right now if open AI starts selling ads.
>> It could be a bigger distribution for
them. Yeah, but people will eventually
you can only spend 10k if you have a 10k
budget, right?
>> If you start splitting 5k openi, 5k
Facebook. Yeah, I'm really curious about
chat GPT ads or see where it will plays
out if people will use an AI that will
give them ads inside and when you know
there is ads into the conversation you
are talking to
>> are you going to serve to be serve an ad
or is that a proper recommendation of
what you are looking for?
>> Yeah, but people know that when they
search a product on Google shopping
>> they see ads as well. It is just told
there add one, add two, add three and
then you go to the normal products.
>> So people are used to it, right?
>> Uh
>> but you have to say that it's an ad. You
can't just
>> But have you seen the tweet about like
the sponsored uh Google like the
placement of the ads on Google page?
Okay. So uh okay, GitHub action software
uh
uh for opens.
So uh I'm just quick experiment here
tech. Okay. So GitHub action software
for open source uh GitHub action.
>> Uh
okay. So you have uh a [__] AI
generated
>> uh section. Then you have videos from
YouTube kind of Reddits.
>> Mhm.
>> Oh, I'm using Brave, so I don't see the
the ads.
>> You need to switch.
>> Yep.
Why am I not seeing ads?
Where are the ads?
Or you just have a
um
alternative
uh quick books.
Okay. A
why why do why I don't have ads?
That's weird.
Here
it instantly starts with ads on the on.
>> Okay. Brav is lit. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Can you share your screen?
>> Yes. One moment.
>> We are so far. We drifted so far from
open.
>> [laughter]
>> We are over our time and we still didn't
discuss what we planned to discuss.
>> I mean, we kind of did. We just need to
do the outro and then I will have the 10
minutes video. That should be fine.
Tech
back.
Okay.
>> Yeah. Only it's on Dutch.
>> Oh, yeah. That's fine. That's fine.
>> But I did the same search query. as
alternative for QuickBooks. Enter.
And yeah, it even starts with one, two,
here with the sponsor, three, four, and
then I go to the AI overview.
>> Okay.
>> Videos and here the real results come
and at the end I have two more. So
almost everything is sponsored.
>> Yeah. Like Yeah. It's not.
And and plus like the blog for videos,
AI generated content like and no like
even like the links
sponsored, you're never going to see
them because now Google search is a
[__] AI reply.
>> Yeah.
>> Like what's the first link? Is that a
sponsor link?
>> Yeah. Yeah. The first one is a
[clears throat] Dutch sponsor link.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Uh yeah. Okay. So
those ones they are even before the AI
>> it is the first thing you see
>> sponsored results.
>> Yeah. But that mean like you need to
compete with Revolute
ads on Google.
>> Good luck.
>> But it's the entire page.
>> Yeah.
>> But this is my whole view. I need to
start scrolling.
>> That's nuts.
>> So also here ads are so much bigger.
It's so much better to just spend money
on ads instead of
>> Yeah.
>> doing sale.
>> If you see this.
>> No, it's true.
>> That's true.
>> But in Ch I think if you do this
>> and you just have one or two ads and
then show the rest of the results, I
don't think people will get used to it.
In the beginning, they will complain.
But
>> yeah, you have the cards at the end of
the conversation like uh view more blah
blah blah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And most people don't even still
don't know that on Google they are
clicking ads.
>> Yeah, I know. Exactly. Yeah, true.
Yeah. Yeah. Because they're not even
reading like Yeah. sponsor. They don't
they don't even know what sponsor mean.
[laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> But I'm I'm really happy with Brave
though.
>> Kind of late.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah,
>> that's good news.
>> Uh cool. Okay. So should we should we
conclude with uh give me give me a two
minutes conclusion so I have a 10
minutes video [laughter]
>> AI is so big we talked about so much and
didn't tell what we want to tell
[laughter]
>> so I think we can do so much more but
>> yeah it looks like AI is going so fast
but I think it will take like two or
three years at least to go but we will
think that it will be next week.
>> Yeah. Oh for sure. And okay so where do
you think like open source will go in
the next six months because I can't ask
you for more long for longer than that.
>> No no no no but yeah I hope that people
on the big open source projects will
just include AI to optimize the incoming
incoming PRs and to [clears throat] make
it even better so it can scale so it can
scale in six months what it did in the
last five years.
>> Yeah. And do you think AI will open
create their own open source project
like a mold book but uh
>> yeah a mold book was all scam right?
>> Yeah.
>> The only thing is why would an AI create
an open-source project for other people
to use if it can just build whatever it
needs itself.
>> And I think that's a good question to
conclude a video.
>> Yeah. If you know the answer, write it
down.
>> Exactly. Please comment and subscribe so
we can see you next week.
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> On the live stream and on the channel.
Mitchell, thank you so much for your
time. We appreciate the chitchat.
>> Yes. Thank you, Vincent.
>> You're welcome. [laughter]
>> And Michelle Bad, thank you so much for
tuning in.
>> We love you.
>> And I think everybody will have to miss
us next week, right? Uh maybe not
because yeah who know
>> who knows maybe
hey subscribe so you can see if we are
going live next week.
>> Yes. [laughter]
Thank you for for watching and chatting.
Bye.
>> Cheers.